hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the power of multiplexing
and applications of the quantity inflex
assay in oncology research and
diagnostics it is presented by Godfrey
grec PhD we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific Thermo Fisher Scientific is a
world leader in serving science whose
mission is to enable customers to make
the world healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity for
more information please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor moderator for
today's event this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits so
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone this event is interactive and
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you can use
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce dr. Greg who
is an associate professor at the
University of Malta he is responsible
for the molecular pathology research
laboratory and director of biotech
innovations
spin-off company the main research topic
aims to identify biomarkers to classify
breast cancer patients into a specific
therapeutic group which will benefit
from activation of phosphatases as a
main Serap utak option dr. Greg has
published more than 25 peer review
publications presented more than 50
conference papers and published five
books afters he is a member of the
molecular pathology working group of the
European Society of pathology an active
member of the European Association of
preventive predictive and personalized
medicine and a member of the global
genomic medicine collaborative dr. Greta
complete bio is found on the lab routes
website please join me in welcoming dr.
Greg I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you very much
so today I will be presenting the power
of multiplexing with the quantity flex
essay so first we're going through the
technology so the biomedical research I
am about to present relies on the
quantity of X si which is a luminix
based multiplex our amazing
luminix technology uses color-coded
magnetic beads that can be conjugated
with antibodies or oligonucleotides
specific to particular Perez's allowing
users to multiplex several targets in
the same world Thermo Fisher Scientific
supplies a variety of luminix best si to
measure RNA or DNA as well as protein
so the quantity term officials luminix
based immunising is called the broker
Alex si with pro cutter flex you can
quantitate up to 80 analyzed in one
sample using only 25 microliters of
plasma or serum
there are several pre-designed panels
available such as immuno oncology or you
can select analytes to configure your
own mix and match panel the contagion
plaques si uses branch DNA technology
for signal amplification to measure gene
expression probing RNA and DNA branch
DNA uses sequential hybridization of
oligonucleotides to a capture target RNA
or DNA in order to amplify a signal for
quantitative measurement thermo Fisher
uses branch DNA in several platforms as
you can see on this slide including gene
expression for s intensity of
hybridization and flows otama tree next
I'll show you how the branch DNA and the
quantum flux assay work in the diagram
to the right first you add your sample
to a beat mix that consists of both the
magnetic
luminate speeds as well as a set of
probes that are used to capture the
target or na during the first incubation
the capture extenders hybridize to the
capture probes conjugated to the beads
while also hybridizing to the target RNA
sequence as you can see in the diagram
this captures the target RNA on to the
desired beat through a process called
cooperative hybridization each beat
cutter has its own target specific set
of probes allowing multiple genes to be
captured on two different beads also
hybridization to the target RNA our
label extenders which provide
the basis for the branched DNA signal
amplification structures these label
extenders are always designed in first
to enhance the specificity of the SI the
third type of probe is the blocking
probe hybridizes to any piece of the
target sequence that is not already
targeted way to capture extenders
ordinal probes the purpose of the
blocking probes is to form a complete
double-stranded piece of RNA protecting
it from
rnases and helping to prevent it and
researchers within the target region the
capture extenders label extenders and
blocking probes all comprise the target
specific probe set designed and provided
by thermal vision next the branched DNA
or Laguna credits form the signal
amplification structure first a pre
amplification amplifier hybridizes to
the labor rated extender fails in the
next incubation many amplifiers
hybridize to each pre amplifier and in
the following incubation many label
probes or laguna Clare's hybridized to
each amplifier the label probe molecule
is conjugated with biotin
so when streptavidin fight for eritrane
is added in the last step a fluorescent
signal is created and measured so now I
would like to introduce the work done
with utilizing the quanta gene assays in
our laboratory our molecular pathology
lab was established in 2008 under the
faculty of medicine surgery department
pathology in the field of oncology
research we have been using the quantity
in Plex si since 2012
mainly in multiplexed form it using two
luminix platform experiments ranged from
cytokine
this transcription profanities engine
expression measurement from various
sources including sylvane's fresh tissue
and formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue which I will refer to in this
presentation as FFP today I should be
focusing on the use of the multiplex
assay to classify a breast cancer
patient providing evidence of the
strength of the quantum flux assays to
find new potential subtypes our group
studies the phosphatase complex protein
phosphatase to a mainly focusing on its
role in the regulation of cancer we
gained experience in utilizing my newton
amount of tissue material to measure
known and not the biomarkers of the
using quantity of black spinels just a
brief introduction of the group and also
to understand the facilities available
so starting from left to right at the
back standing up there is dr. Romina
briefer working on the colorectal cancer
research together with st. Andrews in
Scotland professor Christine sherry
which is the clinical research lead in
our group maria PR christi finished
distributing working on basic research
on the complex that's myself then there
is dr. john Baldacci know who is
performing most dqg and equality gene
essays and also the tissue microarray
experiments in the rhythm detect project
in France in the left we see Christian
sediba who is also an expert in quantity
in essays and laser microdissection
facilities and janice cherry is a
previous shooting working on hair to
resistance and she's working on liquid
biopsies
our commitment is to supply patients
into specific therapeutic groups that
can benefit from P P to a activating
therapy the main objectives are to
derive noted biomarkers defining these
therapeutic groups and adapt our
technologies to measure and set up
predictive indicators as I said the
postdoctoral fellows with ample
experience in quantity in Plexus a dr.
Stanley Banda turbot the Kino are are
those that have the most of the work
presented today in this webinar i
appreciate also the constant support
from the clinical consultants at
moderate hospital professor sherry is
the clinical lead in our group dr. the
Gator known as the concentrate
histopathology and also the surgery
department headed fight of the jaws of
the bone we run various research
projects that make use of the condition
plaques sa ranging from basic research
where we study the biology of the PP to
a complex to translation projects that
involve mobile biomarker discovery and
validation the extent of use of the
technology spread across different types
of tumors we work on breast cancer
colorectal cancer and lately we also
started cervical cancer with the HPV
transforming events and we also work
across different types of sources
including cell lines
FFPE material and liquid biopsies all of
which would require specific selection
of normalizing genes and that attention
of the algorithms required to provide
the accurate results various
achievements were possibility using the
motifs a including the characterization
of two novel biomarkers that provide
information on the activity level of the
58 complex and in fact this year we
actually filed the patent on these novel
firm workers these biomarkers which we
call them P
during this webinar Vav would stand for
people to weigh activity biomarkers now
a little bit interaction on the
phosphatase which is DPP to a complex
with this constant it consists of three
subunits the structural subunit a
because the catalytic subunit C and the
regulate is emitted be there are over 40
different regulatory subunits which can
be grouped into activating regulators
and inhibiting regulators our work and
that of others have shown the
association of differential expression
of the inhibitory regulators of the
feedback PB to a complex with cancer
aggressiveness and development the
complexity and therapeutic options are
actually surprised in a review published
in tumor biology that is indicated in
the slide multiplexing and high
throughput analysis from my new sample
size is the key to investigate these
complexes in patient material so RNA
base as a using the condition that was
optimized in all that with the goal to
identify another subtypes of patients
that can benefit from PP to a activating
therapies this cartoon shows one of the
actions of this phosphatase complex
namely the attenuation of the 880 mTOR
pathway the a KT enter pathway is an
imported pathway which activates
survival and proliferation and the PPTA
complex would be phosphorylated this
target tender for attenuated this
signaling cascade on the right hand side
there is a box with red boxes these are
the tribute away regulators which have
been in business inhibitory function on
the complex of note we mention shipped
away in our webinar expression level of
these core complex subunits and the
regulatory subunits is very informative
and we have done
expression analysis on cellular models
and patient material the numerous
permutation to derive a solid
understanding of the activity of the
enzyme is very complex so we
investigated novel biomarkers associated
with enzyme activity and sensitivity to
perpetuate activators to translate our
findings from basic research into the
clinic we use quantum flux as a to
measure gene expression in archival
material that are well annotated with
routine pathology results and clinical
information we decided to use cohorts
that have at least five years of
clinical information to derive overall
survival and disease progression growth
following mocking of archival material
to FFP slides were prepared and two
cores were taken from each sample
representing the same tumor area one of
the cores was used to produce a tissue
microarray which I will be referring to
it as T MA and the other called
homogenized for the quantity missing in
the case of breast cancer were repeated
also the expression of estrogen receptor
within the panels to correlate with the
diagnostic annotations this slide gives
an overview of our approach to translate
research with inbred depressed and
colorectal cancer research yes to
workflow to classify breast cancer
samples at the molecular level includes
staining whole sections with hemotoxin
an earring stain which I will refer to
as an H and E
tissue stain followed by specific immune
system sustaining such as you know in
this case the istration receptor in
residency a contagion forty plaques si
is used to measure gene expression of
luminal basal
workers epithelium as in caiman workers
and expression of people to a subunits
and tippet away activity
Marcus the luminol baton Marcus used in
this tunnel are well-known markers that
are already published the contagion
plaques si can be used to measure
archival material that is more than 15
years old and this provides the
possibility to associate markers with
clinical and therapy related information
immunised at chemistry was performed on
the PP to a inhibitory regulators to
correlate with the RNA based results
this was done both on both sections
lights and lately tissue microarrays
were used to increase the throughput
this light shows the IHC results of
samples that are positive to the
conjurer's inhibitor of PP towei which
is the inhibitory regulator called
sipped away on the left and the sample
are negative or shipped away on the
right panel each case that represent the
different receptor status of breast
cancer patients namely er positive her2
positive and triple negative which I can
call these t embassies and super
positive cases scoring for different
antibodies is difficult to standardize
with different scoring methods selected
for different markers and also the
subjectivity of scores require extensive
training to achieve concordance between
scores
hence it is difficult to obtain a value
that gives an objective measure of the
complex activity using the investor
chemistry stains of course one has to
appreciate the time required to score
all the samples for multiple markers and
derive a waked value that can associate
with the parlament being assessed in
this case the activity of pivot away
Enzo
to enhance the throughput we assess the
52 regulators and hospitai get in breast
cancer cohorts using tissue microarrays
TMA's the phosphorylation status of the
880 and s 6k which are shown on the far
left of the panels is expected to
reflect the PPTA activity or signaling
activation as shown in the cartoon
before here I am showing two distinct
representative cases showing low
expression across prepatory inhibitors
and as expected this is associated with
the efficient rip it away dependent
attenuation of the mTOR phospho targets
a KD and the six kinase the opposite is
seen in the case below showing an
increased expression of lipitor
regulator inhibitors that companies were
increase the expression of a KT and
Essex - to conclude the IC study the
music of the study we have shown that
correlations using scores as limiting
subjective and very time-consuming
quanta gene RNA flux sa provide us with
a robust method generating quantitative
values optimization requires the
selection of the appropriate normalizing
genes and the proper controls in the
multiplex si preferably markers that can
be compared with known results from
first-line diagnosis done in routine
pathology this slide show the chose the
quantity flex workflow using laser
microdissection so when laser my to this
section a specific part of the tissue is
dissected using a laser and this is
selected depending on the immunostaining
or the H and these things following
death tissues homogenized and used
directly into the yet
this is one of the main advantages of
the contagion assay so there is no need
for RNA extraction see the innocent is
an target amplification in fact as we
seen in the first slide the probes will
bind directly to the RNA target and then
form a scaffold and on which the actual
signal is amplified so the workflow with
sample preparation direct homogenized
lies it into the world target
hybridization and signal amplification
as we seen in the first night following
that the multiplex is detected using the
luminix technology the quanta gene for
diplexer says that we used in these
studies was designed to zoom athenaeus
to measure expression of 30 genes using
effort PE material to modify breast
cancer 8 Baisden luminal classifiers and
6 epithelium as internal markers were
used the tribute to a complex was
represented by the catalytic subunit and
8 rigorously subunits of which four are
inhibitory eighth potential pivot away
pivotal biomarkers were generated from
the basic research work and included in
the phenol in addition 10 normalizing
genes were used to allow selection of
the best normalizing G's and to optimize
desing first we looked at interim
variability using SL line RNA a
regression coefficient of 0.9 I was
obtained in various Intel run
variability assays and hence there is no
significant difference between the
replicas serial whole sections were
homogenized with or without HND stain
and the essay showed that there is no
significant effect of the staining
this is very important observation since
the quantity influx si can be performed
on stained material and proved to be
useful to do laser microdissection in
which tumors can be tumor tumor areas
can be micro dissected in a in a
different tube from normal tissue from
the same section optimizing the si and
developing an algorithm to classify
patients correctly required training
sets first we utilized the in silico
data sets available the Cancer Genome
Atlas breast cancer rnaseq data to
annotate cohorts with the 1050 molecular
classification of luminal and basil
once annotated we used the rnaseq data
available to predict the classification
using the patterns of Jesus in our
essays data normalization was done using
combinations of the normalizing genes in
our design independent after
normalization were performed the
prediction using our classifiers and
compared that to the uh notated append
50 sentence this was done using a PCA
plot following that we integrated our
quantity in RNA expression data we did
the same algorithm the graph on the
right shows a principal component
analysis PCA showing luminal samples in
blue basil samples in red and held to
enrich samples in green this was done
using the classifiers in our panel and
compared these to the annotations
using different 15 classification the
table on the Left shows that using the
TCGA victim the classifier and
classifiers in our planet result in
98.2%
with the 1050 in total 99.4% of
er-positive cases using immunised the
chemistry were classified as limited
cases and 95% of the TM PC case is
classified as basis as exactly
this slide shows that the eighth genes
used in a and it can provide an
excellent luminal basic classification
so we tested and trained the algorithms
using TCGA data set this slide shows the
first quantum plex sa run using FFPE
material from our patient cohort
interestingly there is hundred percent
concordance with hell - enrichment when
comparing our results with the immunised
chemistry and fish results main 6.8% of
ER positives are luminous and hundred
percent of the TMP were classified as
basil this shows that the quantity in
flux si performs well on the performance
is fixed purveyor bedded material next
we looked at the normalized intensity
values distribution among the different
receptor status groups in breast cancer
namely the ER her2 and treat the embassy
to the negative presence the simply used
are homogenized whole sections from FFPE
Motty growing left from right in each
group the first three genes represent
the base in markers the other five genes
represented luminal markers the last
marker on the right in grey shows
expression of these trojan receptor as
expected mr. gene receptor is expressed
only in the ER positive groups as shown
with the red arrow
expression of luminal markers is highest
in the ER positive group and expression
of beta markers is highest in the t
embassy providing confidence in the
results obtained
of interest in one particular case
during this run at the embassy case
characterized by high expression level
of basic markers also showed high
expression of luminous markers given
that the measurements were done using
whole sections who investigated the
kilmer section and identified using H
and D stain to potential tumour sites
having the possibility of staining the
slides for the quanta G flex sa analysis
we might intersect that the identified
abnormal sites under and multiplexing
the samples showed luminal properties
and results indicated that there was
also a difference in the mesenchymal
marker expression Harrod the quantum
flux si was sensitive enough to pick up
a heterogeneous sample and proved to be
useful to analyze low input material
from laser microdissection technology
the data of this particular case the
data is currently being reviewed for
publication and this shows the facility
of delays and vector as you all know
first line diagnosis is done on biopsy
samples contingent on whole sections
actually identified at original samples
giving an interesting observation that
respected samples might one might check
for heterogeneity using these kind of
it's essays
so achieving a good molecular
classification breast cancer provided
the means to investigate whether the
novel PEEP it away activity in biomarker
the PA B's of course all this data was
generated in only one run of multiplex
using the luminix platform using breast
cancers and mines we investigated the
báb and correlated the expression with
sensitivity to pivot away activators
pipa to activity can be measured in
vitro by Aminu precipitation of the
complex and measuring the festivities
activity as you can see in the growth
there's well known that the pivot of
activity in the leukemic cell line k562
is very low to the high expression of
set and hence it is used as a control in
this experiment the burger shows that
whereas the er positive cell line m da
mb 4 5 3 has abnormal
db2a activity DT NBC cell 9 AMD mb -
drew one has a low phosphatase activity
comparable to k562 cell viability assays
were performed on breast cancers - at
night the three emphasis on lines DM and
B two three one bt 20 and HS 5 7 ATT
graph a were sensitive to low dose after
y7 - all a snippet away the Vator
the ic50 was huge reached at 5 micro
molar concentration graph B shows three
the embassies on lines that are not
sensitive to the drug the luminal
ER or her2 positive cell lines are also
not sensitive to the drug a scene graph
D rusty chose to salma is derived from
normality and also not sensitive to the
drug this represents a new potential
therapeutic group versatility also
correlated strongly with the expression
of the 52 a individual
regulator zipped away and with other two
people to eight activation biomarkers
their expression were decreased
following 24 hours of after the wake
7000 edition
so with these essays we identified pp2
activity biomarkers using breast cancer
models silence we we have predicted
sensitivity to 50 activators in sun line
disease was B abs and today we're
working on various VIP pivot away
activators after y7 to all and other
small molecule activating and molecules
called snaps and new sub types of
patients potentially sensitive tooth
maps is being currently conducted in our
labs so the robustness and easy workflow
of contagion flex sa allowed us to
extend the research to colorectal cancer
and those who currently optimizing PSA
to study biomarkers in liquid biopsies
using liquid biopsies shall provide the
means to measure tumor markers in cells
circulating tumor cells or in cell
components such as
exosomes in blood to achieve with their
patient monitoring and to promote
research into early diagnostics in
addition we are now setting up the
quanta gene assay to read these markers
in various patient-derived xenograft
models this will allow us to perform in
vivo experiments using small molecule
that activators of people to wait and
therefore we can correlate the
biomarkers with in vivo sensitivity to
these maps
the challenges in translational research
is the integration of the clinical
diagnostic and therapeutic data and the
availability of the required sample type
to validate findings and prevent sound
clinical utility through the act project
just financed by the motor Council for
science and technology we are addressing
these challenges and also and also
validating and commercializing use of
quantum flux as a for molecular
classification of breast cancer as you
can see this is the slide shows an
overview of the Act project and the
challenges are to provide the samples
which like FFPE tissues fresh samples
for X's and Y's lesions first artist to
do liquid biopsies and the use of TM is
is very useful because and you can
prepare a tea and may end also having
the lies lies aids for the quanta gene
essays in a systematic way
this work has been done through various
collaborations we have both academic and
industrial collaborations and I would
like to also thank the Institute of mica
medicine beads which provided us with a
lot of TNA's from the breast cancer
collection and we are jointly working
with st. Andrews University Scotland on
the colorectal cancer research we just
finished a breast cancer project for the
mullennix with university of Palermo
conduct partners in the in in sicily and
we are pleased to work on liquid
biopsies with the University of Athens
and in Greece previous to all our
waiting in solid tumors we worked on
leukemia research and we were
in jointly with Erasmus Medical Center
and of course our technologies we always
a discussed these with Austrian
Institute of Technology a very good
collaborator and we are moving on to
xenografts know with the came with
Cambridge on the Europa DX project and
working also with American institutions
on the maps the small molecule activated
activities of people away course I would
also like to thank our industrial
partners for and commercialization of
all particular panels that we have going
very well thank you dr. Gregg for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. Graf please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click on the send
button we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for okay so
let's get started our first question is
if you encounter any issues with
degraded RNA or RNA protein
cross-linking in your FFPE samples and
if so how did you overcome this okay so
RNA degradation and also modification of
the RNA by de formaldehyde in the FFPE
material is definitely a major challenge
and for technologies that that of course
require PCR amplification of the targets
that would require any extraction and
eventually see DNA synthesis of course
as I mentioned before one of the major
advantages of the quanta gene si that
that actually dissented is homogenized
and then the by date is put directly
into the si this means that you don't
need to do any PCR amplification or any
extractions because the branch DNA
technology is based is based on
amplification of the signal but
amplification of the of the target and
of course tended of course lately
through also the act project we also did
an experiment where we degraded RNA from
a cell line using heat treatment over
time and when when the treatment the RNA
is degraded with fragments less than 200
base pairs we can also i quantify
specific markers on on that material
which means that we can actually read
and quantify material when RNA is
degraded
how old are the FFPE blocks used and
what is the minimum amount of sample in
the input well we were successful with
archival FFPE samples in general and
most of our work would we would use FS
B's and as old as 15 years we can go
back to 15 years and actually we don't
use FFP materia which is this is it has
to be about 5 to 10 years old for sure
that's because this will give us the
opportunity to have clinical antara few
critical data with it and as I said I
mean the quantity of plaques si has an
advantage that one can run the plaques
on minimum amount of material but also
as I said before also on degraded
material so I phases samples can be used
now because we can use all this material
and you can go back in 15 15 years of
course we can we can sort of validate
quickly predictive biomarkers of course
as long as the therapy is constant and
that the this relevant to this
predictive value that we would need and
to study how do you normalize the data
giving you start from crude extract
okay so RNA samples it is optimized in
the normal way so if you start with RNA
sample and it's important to have the
same my crimps of RNA per sample and we
move on to normalize normalize that data
with normalizing genes across the
samples of course this all depends on
the on the experimental design form for
its own eyes but when using ss3 material
that not that is not as easy okay first
of all it is important to start with
similar amounts of tissues and keep all
information which is relevant to the
input sample so that you can refer to if
there is something if your results are
not I'm not agreeing with what you
expect for instance in case of whole
sections for instance we derive area of
cellularity from the digital images and
of course we know the thickness of the
sections in case of laser Michael
dissection that is easier because the
microscope microscope will give us the
input area and also the thickness would
know it beforehand and although this
information is important I mean the old
essays or essay should be optimized in a
way the optimization would mean that you
need to study well the normalizing genes
that you will be used to normalize data
with and of course these normalizing
genes will be different for specific
tissue types and also sample types we as
a group have developed a couple of
algorithms to actually assess and select
these best normalizing genes for these
different assays and for different types
of samples and that's basically I mean
there's a lot of work beforehand and to
actually norm to her a good panel of
normalizing G's we don't use only one
normalizing gene per panel but in
general we have at least
fine normalizing genes Peron
then we have an algorithm to actually
normalize the data with that it is very
important that every experiment would
have a control gene and that you already
have some information it on so for
example in breast cancer we always put
the Eastridge in receptor because we
know from routine pathology that the
sample is er positive or not and so this
is something that is important to put
with the dependence and therefore so
depends on the design of the experiment
well I would like to once again to thank
dr. Gregg for his presentation I would
also like to thank our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits I want to advise that a poll
question will appear on your screen you
may select your answer then close the
poll question by clicking on the X in
the right corner the question is are you
interested in learning more about
multiplexing from a company
representative thank you before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2018 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
when your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye